Barocke Fassaden treffen auf moderne
Architektur:
Nach acht Jahren Bauzeit ist die
Neuinterpretation des historischen
Barockschlosses in der Mitte Berlins so gut
wie fertig.
Außen und innen treffen überall Alt und Neu
zusammen.
Beherbergt wird hier zukünftig das „Humboldt
Forum“,
ein neuer Ort für Kultur und Wissenschaft.
Das Humboldt Forum ist kein Schloss.
Das Humboldt Forum ist
ein radikaler Neubau, der –
so hat es der Bundestag beschlossen –
aber an das alte Berliner Schloss erinnert,
indem
draußen an drei Fassaden und auch hier in
dem zentralen Hof die Fassaden
des Vorgängerbaus genau rekonstruiert
worden sind.
Sogar Originalteile des alten Schlosses sind
in den Neubau integriert.
Vor der schrittweisen Eröffnung glänzt erst
einmal die reine Architektur.
Und die erzählt deutsche Geschichte.
Seine barocke Fassade erhält das Schloss im
18. Jahrhundert.
Im Zweiten Weltkrieg stark beschädigt, lässt
es die DDR-Führung 1950 sprengen.
An seiner Stelle entsteht der Palast der
Republik, Sitz der DDR-Volkskammer.
1989: Die DDR-Bürger schaffen ihr eigenes
Regime ab.
Ab 2006 wird der Palast der Republik
abgerissen – nach vielen Debatten.
2012 beginnt der Bau der Neuinterpretation
des Schlosses.
Die Kosten: 677 Millionen Euro, teilweise
finanziert durch Spenden.
Die Geschichte des Ortes soll auch in den
geplanten Ausstellungen beleuchtet werden –
und vieles mehr.
Es geht natürlich auch um die großen
Themen, die die Sammlungen
der ethnologischen Museen hier mit ins Haus
bringen.
Es geht um Kolonialismus, um Kolonialität, es
geht um die Gebrüder Humboldt, es geht um
wirklich eine globale Perspektive von heute
auch auf den historischen Zusammenhang,
den dieses Haus hier abbildet.
Hier wurde die Architektur des
Schlossneubaus erdacht:
im norditalienischen Vicenza.
Architekt Franco Stella gewann 2008 den
Wettbewerb zum Schlossbau.
Die wichtigsten Straßen, Plätze und Bauten
des historischen Zentrums [von] Berlin waren
auf das Schloss bezogen.
Mit der Rekonstruktion werden diese
Beziehungen wieder erlebbar.
Die Corona-Pandemie verhindert die jetzt
eigentlich geplante
festliche Teileröffnung des Schlosses.
Berliner und Berlin-Besucher können sich
aber bereits an der Außenansicht erfreuen.
Wir könnten loslegen und bitter ist es,
dass wir das ohne Publikum machen müssen,
also diesen Meilenstein begehen,
denn es ist ja ein Haus für uns alle,
für Menschen aus aller Welt.
Und wir hoffen, dass bald denn auch wirklich
das Publikum hierherkommt, denn für die
machen wir das.
Das neue alte Berliner Schloss:
ein Bauwerk mit Geschichte –
und einer barocken Fassade,
hinter der sich viel Modernes verbirgt.